All right, guys, our next guest legitimately
earned her place on the world stage.
She is the most decorated gymnast of all
time and American hero.
Please welcome the goat, Simone Biles.
Hey, look at that.
Hey, Simone. Hello.
So you had a big comeback in 2023.
Let's get into it. I just want to say it's
so good to see you back.
Yes, indeed. How does it feel competing
again?
It feels surreal.
I didn't think after Tokyo Olympics I would
actually be competing again.
So this year I just took each day as a
blessing and I ended up competing, so I
couldn't ask for more.
You have five gymnastics moves named after
you, right? So do you have a favorite move
and can you still do all five of the moves?
That's funny. I can actually still do four
out of the five.
Oh, snap.
Okay. Like one of them is too hard that I
can't even do it anymore.
Um, but we're working on it.
We're working on it, so I don't really have
a favorite.
I guess there's scary to most scary.
But- which one is the scariest?
The scariest, I think, is my Biles two on
vault, which I just competed in Belgium in
October.
Yeah, I would have said that.
You know, I would have said the Biles to two
on vault. Uh, that's what I would have came
out of the gate with. That's you know, I
don't even know if you know this about me,
but I did a little gymnastics.
Did you? Yeah.
From age. What, to, uh.
How old was I? Oh, my God, I think I was, I
think I was, I, I think I was probably 12.
That's deep. Yeah. Probably 12.
I was a late bloomer, but I had a lot of
success. Simone I only had two moves named
after me. One of them, one of them was
called the get the f*** back.
Uh huh, uh, get get the f*** back up off
this. Yeah.
That's because, uh, that's a flip.
Yeah, the back flip. Because they say when I
flip, anybody can get kicked in the mouth.
Yeah.
So get the f*** back.
Yeah. Yeah.
You need to get your ass back.
Yeah. I'm coming in hot.
And then number two was number two.
Well, number two, I'm not gonna get into
number two, because number two got banned.
It got banned completely.
One of the only moves to ever get banned.
Yeah. Congrats, by the way, on your
marriage. This is big.
I want to talk to you about the bachelorette
party. What was the good stuff?
Lots of tequila, a lot of boat days.
I mean, we had a blast.
I think the craziest part was, like, I
sliced my foot open on the golf cart.
Like going to one of the bars.
You ain't supposed to do that.
And I was like, oh, that looks deep.
But like, we're just going to have to keep
moving because there's not real like
hospital on the island that we're at.
Okay, so, um.
You just gotta bleed to death.
You gotta let this bleed out.
Yeah. Take a chance.
Yeah, take a chance.
My husband's family was there.
They got me right. So we just kept it
pushing.
That's crazy though. She did a bachelorette
party in the same radius as the husbands
family and her mother.
That's a that's.
A. Oh, everybody was together partying.
Yeah. You know, we did mine underground.
Yeah, we-. What's that mean?
Yeah, we were.
Off the
radar.
Oh, okay. Mine. We went deep with it.
Yeah, we went real deep.
Now your husband is in the NFL, right?
Yes. Who do you think is the better athlete.
In the house? I think we're good at our own
sports. We've tried to pin each other
against, um, on like, difficulty, ability
and all of that stuff.
So at the end of the day, gymnastics is
harder if he agrees or not.
Wow. Yeah, that's a that's a nice politician
answer. But here's the truth.
I'm not trying to stir anything up in that
household.
I know your name. That's what I'm saying.
That's all I'm gonna say. I know your name.
You know what I'm saying?
So let's go back.
Let's go back to what you just said, which
is that, uh, gymnastics is much harder.
It sounds like this has been a household
fight for some time.
You want to get into it now?
Maybe we clear it up.
We fought over it a couple times, and then we
vowed once we got married, we wouldn't talk
about it again. But it keeps coming up every
time. But, uh, he has done my workout in the
gym and he can barely do it.
And then I went to their NFL workout.
A lot of shots. And I crushed it.
It's a lot of shots fired.
Shots fired.
She's doing a lot of under.
I mean, it's.
A lot of uppercuts being thrown.
We with you. Wow. I mean, I guess the other
big question on everybody's minds is will we
see you in Paris?
Good question.
You know, everybody keeps asking this
question.
You feel free to answer or not.
But we want you to answer it.
Um, that's the end goal.
And I'll be there regardless of if I'm on
the floor or if I'm in the stands.
Do you want to compete or do you want to
just, you know, be the legend?
I hope I'm on the floor.
Because you're already a legend today.
Yeah, I just do my gymnastics and then the
committee selects the team, so.
Got it.
You want me to call somebody because.
Yes. I don't
know if you know this, but Kevin's a big deal
in gymnastics.
So I'm a big deal.
He can make a happen for you.
All you got to do is go to my website.
Kevin Hart highlights gymnastics.org net dot
dot dot back to f*** up back to f*** up
flip. That's what it is.
Simone thank you so much for the time.
Uh, we knew that you would stick the landing
here.